champion big wave surfers Garrett
McNamara and Keely Monroe don't just
listen to the call of nature
they ride it
obsessed with conquering new extreme
waves they decided to ride a glacier
tsunami and gain one and a half million
hits this one had me kind of at the edge
of my seat
so what is a tsunami doing racing away
from the cliff edge as places are
constantly moving when they reached the
end with the sea they start speed up and
this means that they stretch out this
creates large crevasses in the glacier
now it comes to a point where these
blocks the forms break off and fall into
the ocean of displacing a large amount
of water and this is what gives you the
nice big wave that these guys are
surfing a lot so the surfers have a wave
but what makes this the perfect spot to
catch a big break an ocean wave travels
a very long time just as a ripple once
it gets to the shore as soon as the
depth is shallow enough it starts to
break these guys have picked an area
where it's already very shallow so soon
as the ice falls in and forms a wave it
breaks almost immediately to give them a
surfable wave is this genius or is it
just craziness I think it's genius
because they've managed to find the
exact location where all of this will
work
combined with the correct amount of
craziness to actually try it